Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先简单通知大家一件现在正在发生、非常让人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“奔向经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Dreaming of becoming an assistant psychologist but worried about making ends
这些原则都对你适用。本次挑战赛还有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想啦。快去访问我的 Linktree“Dr. Marianne Trent”，或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，我们开始今天的节目吧。梦想成为一名助理心理学家，但又担心难以维持
meet? You're not alone. Many aspiring psychologists face the tough reality of low pay, high living costs and the pressure to gain experience at any cost. In today's episode, we dive into the financial challenges of assistant psychologist roles, explore the hidden costs you might not have considered and discuss whether what is often considered a crucial or important career step is really accessible to everyone. If you're wondering how to balance your passion with your paycheck, then my chat with our guest today, Sam, is going to be for you. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Welcome along to one of my very special episodes, which is an assistant psychologist series. Without any further ado, let's dive
生计？你并不孤单。许多有志于成为心理学家的人都面临着残酷的现实：薪酬低、生活成本高，以及不惜一切代价积累经验的压力。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨助理心理学家岗位的财务挑战，深入了解你可能没有考虑过的隐藏成本，并讨论这个通常被认为至关重要或重要的职业阶梯是否真的对每个人都触手可及。如果你在纠结如何在热情与薪水之间找到平衡，那么我和今天的嘉宾萨姆（Sam）的交谈一定会对你有所帮助。希望你会觉得非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。欢迎收听我的特别系列节目之一，即助理心理学家系列。话不多说，我们直接切入主题，看看在现代 NHS（英国国民健康制度）中，当一名助理心理学家的经济负担到底大不大。我们稍后见。
right in and see just how affordable it is or isn't to be an assistant psychologist in the modern NHS. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along to the podcast today, Samantha Airey, who is a qualified counsellor. Hi, Sam. Hi, nice to see you. Yes, indeed. Thank you for reaching out to me to suggest a topic of conversation. I think I'd been discussing on my socials, assistant psychologists and kind of issues around that and kind of thinking about honorary psychologist roles, which had provoked a conversation between us about the affordability of roles like assistant psychologist hadn't we? Yeah I think working as an AP although it's great experience and it's considered you know a really normal pathway to the D.C.L.E. it comes with its pitfalls because quite a lot of the posts are full-time and yet they are quite low bandings within the NHS.
嗨，今天我非常高兴能在播客中迎来萨曼莎·艾里（Samantha Airey），她是一位合格的咨询师。嗨，萨姆。嗨，很高兴见到你。确实如此。谢谢你主动联系我并提出这个谈话主题。我想我之前在社交媒体上讨论过助理心理学家以及与之相关的一些问题，还考虑过荣誉心理学家（honorary psychologist）的职位，这引发了我们之间关于像助理心理学家这类职位经济负担能力的讨论，对吧？是的，我认为担任 AP（助理心理学家）虽然能获得很棒的经验，并且被认为通往 D.Clin.Psy（临床心理学博士）是一条非常正常的途径，但它也有其隐患，因为相当多的职位都是全职的，然而在 NHS 中的薪酬级别却相当低。
So where I'm at at the moment, I'm already a band six, so I'd have to take a pay cut to do one of those roles. Oh gosh, yes, you really would, wouldn't you? And I know that you are a mother and that you have perhaps more overheads than the people that might be at an earlier stage of their family planning. But also, you know, you're potentially competing against people who might be 21. And so as our lives progress, we do get more and more bills and regular kind of direct debits. And we're both saying that we've got children that are in
所以就我目前的状况而言，我已经达到了第 6 级（band six），如果去做其中一个职位，我的薪水反而会下降。哦天哪，是的，确实如此，对吧？我知道你是一位母亲，而且比起那些处于家庭规划更早阶段的人，你可能承担更多的事，但同时，你也在和那些可能才 21 岁的人竞争。随着我们生活的推进，我们的账单和各种常规直接扣款确实越来越多。我们俩都提到过，我们的孩子也都在
year seven of secondary school as well. And they come with their own overheads like he's got his own mobile contract and stuff now my son has so these outgoings are definitely higher you know as our lives progress but it makes me think about when I was an assistant psychologist and actually at that point my band four role was about 13 000 pounds so the rates have gone up a lot but should we have a look at the current agenda for change, hourly and yearly rates together? Yes, so I think AP roles tend to be band four or five. I think it really depends on where you are in the country. But the starting wage for that is around about £13.57. That's for a band four.
中学七年级（初一）。他们也有自己的开销，比如我儿子现在有自己的手机合约等等。随着生活的推进，这些日常支出确实更高了。这让我想起当年我当助理心理学家的时候，实际上当时我的第 4 级职位年薪大约是 13,000 英镑。所以现在的薪酬标准已经提高了很多，但我们要不要把当前的“变革议程”（agenda for change）的小时薪资和年薪资放在一起看看呢？是的，所以我认为 AP 的职位往往属于第 4 级或第 5 级。我认为这 realmente 取决于你在国家的哪个地区。但第 4 级的起薪大约是每小时 13.57 英镑。那是针对第 4 级的。
So although some might say that that's great, I guess it depends on what you've done before, like where you might have come from and what your lifestyle has been like. But for me, already nearly 40, I've worked at a band six now for the last three or four years, it's substantial pay cut to do an AP role for me. Absolutely and when we think about the living wage which is about £12 or something like that at the moment what I'm aware is of that we you know we could be getting not that dissimilar amount of money for a job where essentially no or much lower qualifications are needed with less risk, with less stress, with less kind of multidisciplinary team working. Perhaps working in a shop, for example, if you
所以尽管有些人可能会觉得这很棒，但我想这取决于你之前做过什么，比如你之前的背景以及你的生活方式是怎样的。但对我来说，快 40 岁了，在过去三四年里我一直拿着第 6 级的薪水，如果让我去担任一个 AP 的职位，那将是大幅度的降薪。完全正确。当我们考虑到约 12 英镑左右的“生活工资”（living wage）时，我意识到，我们可以做一份本质上不需要学历或学历要求低得多、风险更小、压力更小、跨学科团队合作也更少的工作，却能拿到相差无几的薪水。比如在商店工作，如果你拿的是最低生活工资，你甚至还可能获得员工折扣等福利。而我们对助理心理学家的要求是他们必须是大学毕业生。他们可能还拥有硕士学位。这与你在国家最低工资或生活工资岗位上所期望的工作类型不尽相同。
were getting the living minimum wage, then you might even get bonus of staff discount as well. What we're asking of our assistant psychologists is that they are a graduate. They might also have a master's. These are not necessarily the same types of work that you might be expecting from somebody in a national minimum or living wage role. No, it's a position of responsibility, isn't it? We're required to do regular CPD. We're required to work in a safe way you know we're working with people's lives we're not flipping burgers and I used to do that you know we need that role but I think that maybe we're not paying people and what what they deserve and also we're seeing that in the NHS trust I work for we're struggling to get people into the roles that are necessary for the likes of inpatient, that's becoming a problem. Absolutely. I was talking to my brother the other day,
不，这是一个充满责任的职位，对吧？我们需要进行定期的 CPD（持续专业发展）。我们需要以安全的方式工作，你知道的，我们在处理人们的生命，我们不是在翻汉堡——我以前干过那个。我们需要这个职位，但我觉得也许我们没有给人们应得的薪酬。此外，我们看到在我工作的 NHS 信托基金（NHS trust）中，我们很难招到住院部等急需的岗位人员，这正在成为一个问题。绝对的。我前几天跟我哥哥聊天，
and he used to work in Marks and Spencers, and I used to work in Boots. And my starting wage was £2.97 an hour. And he said, oh, mine was more than that. Mine was about £4.50, even in those days. They always paid better, it seems. Even these days, the idea that I could be working in that role that I really loved and had a great time in, getting paid a very similar wage to that of an assistant psychologist is slightly mind-boggling. Yeah, it's crazy, isn't it? And in those moments when you're feeling burnt out, overwhelmed by the role and the person in front of you, should we be working in a shop instead?
他以前在玛莎百货（Marks and Spencers）工作，我以前在博姿（Boots）工作。我当时的起薪是每小时 2.97 英镑。他说，哦，我的比那多，即使在那个年代，我的时薪也有大约 4.50 英镑。看来他们给的薪水总是更好。即使在今天，一想到我可以做那份我真的很喜欢、度过了美好时光的工作，而薪水却和助理心理学家的薪水差不多，这多少有点令人匪夷所思。是的，这太疯狂了，不是吗？而在那些你感到精疲力竭、被工作以及面前的来访者压得喘不过气来的时刻，我们是不是应该去商店工作呢？
You know, it makes you wonder, doesn't it? It really does. You know, why am I doing this? Why am I putting myself through this? And I think especially when we're looking at routes into professionally qualified psychologists, where there's no guaranteed pot of gold at the end of the rainbow, it can make us question why we're doing it. But do we know what the average rent is at the moment in the UK in terms of affordability? Well national statistics for England I mean Scotland and Wales might be slightly different but it says the average rent is £1,276 but if we look at the take-home for band 4 for example monthly it's £1,885 so you've not got much wiggle room there for all your other bills and that doesn't even include things like pension deductions really you know when we're
你知道，这真让人禁不住去想，对吧？确实如此。你知道，我为什么要这么做？我为什么要让自己经受这些？而且特别是当我们审视通往专业合格心理学家的途径时，隧道尽头并没有保证有一pot 金子，这让我们不得不质疑自己为什么要这么做。但是我们知道目前英国的平均租金在负担能力方面是多少吗？嗯，英格兰的国家统计数据——我是说苏格兰和威尔士可能会略有不同——显示平均租金是 1,276 英镑。但如果我们看例如第 4 级的月收入，那是 1,885 英镑，所以你支付其他所有账单的余地非常小，而且这甚至还不包括养老金扣除之类的费用。真的，当我们在
looking at trying to diversify our workforce and have it better represent the people in our country and the people that we serve we would want a cross-section of abilities, a cross-section of kind of age range of ethnic diverse factors. But really, we are firmly putting the ball in the court of people who can afford to live on very low rent, perhaps even no rent situations by staying in their parents' homes. Absolutely. It does feel like the majority of applicants in their 20s, in fact, I looked on the alternative handbook for this year, there's only around 6% that are 35 plus and over. So it speaks volumes. I found that quite surprising, actually.
寻求劳动力多元化，并希望它更能代表我们国家的人民以及我们所服务的人民时，我们会希望有各种能力、各种年龄段、不同种族多元化因素的横截面。但实际上，我们却把皮球稳稳地踢给了那些能够承担非常低租金、甚至是通过住在父母家里而实现零租金生活的人。完全是这样。感觉大多数申请者都在 20 多岁。事实上，我查了今年的替代手册（alternative handbook），35 岁及以上的申请者只有大约 6%。这说明了很多问题。我发现这其实挺让人惊讶的。
Even that I have to put it in my application that I'm a mature applicant it just feels crazy when I thought a declin was supposed to be like something that you aimed for after working in mental health for a while you know and building up experience and knowledge and taking that on to the declin it sounds like people are just going from university into that now. Absolutely. But obviously, in terms of the way that applications are screened, your personal data wouldn't be looked at and that would be held separately. But of course, it doesn't take an expert to look at the years you did your GCSEs, for example, or the years you did your A-levels to be able to work out a candidate's age and even the range of different jobs and different relevant or non-relevant clinical experiences does make it quite easy to kind of roughly work out what an applicant's age would be
甚至我不得不在申请表中写明我是一名大龄申请者，这感觉太疯狂了。我以前以为临床心理学博士学位应该是在心理健康领域工作了一段时间、积累了经验和知识后才去追求的目标，你知道的，然后再去攻读博士。听起来现在大家都是直接从大学毕业就去申请了。当然。但显然，在筛选申请的方式方面，你的个人数据是不会被查看的，这些信息是分开保存的。但当然，不需要专家去看，只要看你考 GCSE（普通中等教育证书）的年份，或者考 A-level（高级水平考试）的年份，就能大致推算出候选人的年龄，甚至各种工作以及相关或不相关的临床经验的跨度，也让人很容易大致推算出申请者的年龄。
yeah and of course you know this goes beyond the pay right now because many people are thinking of assistant psychologists' roles as being almost a gold standard into getting the kind of experiences, the kind of supervision, the kind of reflection, the kind of opportunities that do make it more likely that you can progress into a qualified psychologist route. So whilst we might be disadvantaging people now because they can't afford to work as an assistant, we might in essence be capping their later earnings if they can't then progress into professional qualified roles. Yeah, it can feel like we are stuck. I know that we get increments on the bandings now, but it kind of feels like I'm stuck here this is
是的，当然，这不仅仅是眼前的薪水问题，对吧？因为许多人认为助理心理学家的职位几乎是获得特定经验、特定监督、特定反思、特定机会的黄金标准，这些经验和机会确实增加了你晋升为合格心理学家的可能性。因此，虽然我们现在可能因为人们负担不起助理的工作而让他们处于不利地位，但如果他们随后无法晋升为专业合格的职位，我们在本质上可能就封顶了他们未来的收入。是的，这会让人觉得我们被困住了。我知道我们现在在薪级上有增资（increments），但感觉我被困在这里了，这就是
my place now as a as a counsellor I'm in a solid band six role and I can't go anywhere unless I want to do management if the declin's not open to me you know part of our well-being at work is to feel like we've got somewhere to go somewhere to grow and professionally So it's super important, I think, and something that is kind of mixed within the talk in therapies or psychological professions arena of the NHS. That is such an important point, Sam, because actually what we know from looking at Maslow's hierarchy is that we need to think that we can kind of keep moving forwards and keep self-actualising. And, you you know looking at Dr. Claire Plumley's special series over the summer Burnout Bites if we don't feel like we're
我作为咨询师的现状，我处于一个稳固的第 6 级岗位，除非我想做管理，否则我哪儿也去不了。如果临床心理学博士学位对我来说走不通，你知道的，我们在工作中的幸福感有一部分来自于觉得我们有地方可去、有地方可以成长和实现专业发展。所以这超级重要，我认为这是 NHS 的心理治疗或心理专业领域中普遍存在的一种复杂情绪。这是一个非常重要的问题，萨姆，因为实际上从马斯洛的需求层次理论中我们了解到，我们需要认为自己能够继续前进并不断实现自我。而且，正如克莱尔·普卢姆利博士（Dr. Claire Plumley）在今年夏天的特别系列节目“职业倦怠咬啮”（Burnout Bites）中所讲的，如果我们觉得没有
getting that then we actually whisk boring out and burning out because we're kind of feeling stuck and stagnant and like it's all a bit futile. Yeah, absolutely. I don't think these factors are really fully considered within some of the teams. Annual reviews and the questionnaires that are routinely sent out to staff consider this, but in reality, it is much done about it. Yeah. And, you know, if and when you get onto a professional paid psychology training role, I remember going from band four to band six and essentially feeling a bit like I'd won the lottery. Whereas what I know that the trusts kind of insist on these days is that if you're starting a new role, is that you start
得到那种发展，我们实际上就会感到无聊和精疲力竭，因为我们会觉得自己被困住了、停滞不前，一切都有点徒劳。是的，完全如此。我认为在一些团队中，这些因素并没有得到充分的考虑。定期考核和例行发给员工的问卷确实考虑到了这一点，但在现实中，并没有采取太多实际行动。是的。而且，如果你进入了带薪的专业心理学培训岗位，我记得自己从第 4 级升到第 6 级时，本质上感觉有点像中了大奖。然而据我所知，信托基金如今坚持的是，如果你开始一个新的职位，如果你对该信托基金来说是新人，你就要从该级别的起薪点开始。
at the bottom of the increment for that banding if you're new to that trust. So in essence, you could go from being a band six NHS in a neighbouring trust to then starting your new role as a trainee and be financially worse off. Absolutely. And where I am up in the North West, the next trust along geographically, my job would be a band seven so it would be even more of a decrease in pay really for some I think there needs to be some consideration we shouldn't be trying to get more psychologists it's a much needed role and yet not being able to make it affordable for those staff you know the job's already hard enough we don't need life to be had too yeah and i think this you know this speaks volumes of the general sense of kind of psychology pay in the nhs of general pay across the nhs this
所以本质上，你可能会从一个邻近信托基金的 NHS 第 6 级员工，变成一个作为培训生开始新工作的人，财务状况反而更糟了。完全正确。在我所在的西北部，地理位置上的下一个信托基金，我的工作将是第 7 级，所以对某些人来说，薪水实际上会下降得更多。我认为这需要有所考量。我们本不该为了招收更多心理学家而发愁——这是一个非常急需的岗位，然而却无法让这些员工负担得起生活。你知道，工作本身已经够难了，我们不需要把生活也弄得这么艰难。是的，我觉得这说明了 NHS 中心理学薪酬的普遍状况，以及整个 NHS 薪酬的普遍状况。这
isn't just linked to nhs but you know i don't want this to sound like my diamond shoes are too tight but when i was an 8a in the nhs it actually was not affordable for me to go to band 8b because i was part-time and at that time it would have meant that i was actually worse off because of the way that the pension contributions were calculated so i'd be potentially doing a service lead job with more stress with more responsibility for less take-home pay which i just wasn't going to be doing. And I guess if we were looking to increase the pay or the banding for assistant psychologists and entry routes into psychology, we'd need to be thinking about what happened to the qualified routes at band seven and beyond as well. And this isn't an easy fix. This isn't a quick conversation, but this is just us shedding
不仅仅与 NHS 有关，你知道的，我不想听起来像是在抱怨“我的钻石鞋太紧了”（指无病呻吟），但当我在 NHS 担任 8a 级时，我实际上负担不起去升 8b 级，因为我是兼职的。当时的情况意味着，由于养老金缴款计算方式的原因，我的实际收入反而会变少。因此，我可能会去做一份承担更多压力、更多责任、由服务主导的工作，换来的却是更少的到手工资，这种事我是绝对不会干的。我想如果我们希望提高助理心理学家以及进入心理学领域的途径的薪酬或级别，我们就需要考虑第 7 级及以上级别的合格岗位会发生什么。这不是一个简单的解决办法，这不是一次简短的对话，但这只是我们在揭露真相并为之发声。我知道 2008 年及以后实行的薪酬冻结，真的让有资格的生活以及通往培训和有资格生活的途径变得非常缺乏回报。
some light and giving some oxygen to that. And I know that the pay freezes that kind of happened 2008 and beyond have really, really made qualified life and the routes into training and qualified life very much less gratifying. Yeah yeah and obviously with being a counsellor really the psychology route that I should in theory be going on is the counselling psychology but that isn't a funded program and that's what really highlighted all this to me I'm priced out of taking that on and someone online once said to me don't worry they hand out deodorants and and things and vouchers at uni and I was just blown away that actually it seems socially acceptable that we should be financially disadvantaging ourselves for the greater
是的，是的。显然，作为一个咨询师，理论上我应该走的心理学途径是咨询心理学，但那不是一个有资金资助的项目，这正是真正向我突显所有这一切的原因。我被高昂的学费挤出了这个项目。网上曾有人对我说：“别担心，他们在大学里发放除臭剂、各种东西和优惠券。”我当时震惊了，原来社会上竟然可以接受我们为了成为心理学家的“伟大事业”而在经济上让自己处于不利地位。
good of becoming a psychologist um mad oh gosh don't worry we're not going to pay you but here's a free roll on you know enjoy that carry that around in your bag at least you won't smell when you're really stressed you know offering all these services to our to our clients that said i don't want people who are listening to this to feel dissuaded necessarily. If you are a trained counsellor, for example, it's not impossible that you can get a funded training route to be, for example, a clinical psychologist. There is no guaranteed route into this. There never was. We need to look at broadening people's experiences, still encouraging them to have opportunities to kind of reflect, to be well supervised, to be thinking about access to different clinical populations and different skills. I know that's a separate conversation, but it also feels like
呃，太疯狂了。天哪，别担心，我们不付你薪水，但这里有一张免费的餐券，享受吧，把它装在包里随身带着，至少你在压力极大的时候不会有体臭。你知道的，我们为客户提供所有这些服务。话虽如此，我并不希望听到这些的人感到气馁。如果你是一名训练有素的咨询师，例如，要获得带薪培训途径成为一名临床心理学家的可能性并不是没有。通往这里的途径从来没有保证过。我们需要考虑拓宽人们的经验，仍然鼓励他们有机会进行反思、接受良好的监督、思考如何接触不同的临床群体和不同的技能。我知道这是另一个话题，但它同样感觉
an important one. But I hear what you're saying is it's very much harder when you've got stable predictable factors and dependence to get what would feel like a more reliable path to something like the clinical psychology doctorate absolutely it makes me wonder what the reliable path is you know it's so different isn't it for lots of people mine's certainly been unconventional with doing the conversion masters to to get qualified even to apply but I think as well it's it's kind of making me think that it's broadening my horizons it's making me think about how I can improve my situation academically clinically financially and how I can do workarounds I think ultimately it'll make me a stronger clinician but when you're having those days where it feels not affordable or you
非常重要。但我明白你的意思，当你拥有稳定、可预测的因素和家属时，要走上一条感觉更可靠的道路（比如临床心理学博士学位）要困难得多。完全是这样。这让我怀疑什么才是可靠的途径。你知道，对许多人来说，这太不一样了，不是吗？我自己的途径当然也是非传统的，通过攻读转换硕士学位才获得资格，甚至才有资格申请。但我也认为，这让我大开眼界，让我思考如何能在学术上、临床上、财务上改善自己的现状，以及我如何能够找到变通的办法。最终，这会让我成为一名更强大的临床医生。但当你经历那些觉得负担不起或被拒之门外的日子时，
feel boxed out you know then it's tough isn't it? It is and you know before I became a mother I could have tightened my own purse strings and just thought well well, I won't buy new shoes and I'm okay to just keep wearing these trousers to work. But when you are a mother, sometimes you have to obviously buy things like new school shoes every year and new uniforms. But also, you don't always want to be the mother that's saying, no, I can't afford that. And I know that will resonate with you because, you know, even in myself as a mother, you know, children want all the time, but when it comes down to need, you know, actually they do need something. Or if even the relentless one pounds that you've got to take into school for, I don't know, whatever day it is this week, there's not always going to be, it's not a magic porridge pot of money. There's not always going to be it's not a magic porridge pot of money there's not always
那就太艰难了，不是吗？确实如此。而且你知道，在我成为母亲之前，我可以勒紧裤腰带过日子，心想：好吧，我不买新鞋了，我可以继续穿着这条裤子去上班。但当你成为母亲时，有时你显然必须买一些东西，比如每年买新的校服鞋和新校服。而且，你并不总是想成为那个说“不，我买不起”的母亲。我知道这会引起你的共鸣，因为，你知道的，即使是我自己作为母亲，孩子们总是想要这想要那，但当落到“需要”上时，你知道的，他们确实需要某些东西。或者哪怕是那些你不得不带到学校去的、区区一英镑的零钱——不管这周是什么日子——那并不是一个万能的“聚宝盆”。钱并不是随时都会有的。当你有多张嘴要喂饱时，你的手头就会更紧。
going to be that money there and you are just more strapped for cash when you've got more mouths to feed absolutely i try to use it as a life lesson i suppose for my children to budget and to think about where it's best place to spend money i think that's a life skill that we don't always learn in schools or I didn't but yeah you've obviously always got to keep one eye on the table the food what's coming in and also you know like doing my master's I needed to buy a laptop you know and now that's pretty much out of date so if I do get on the doctor, I'll need another one. There's always something that's competing with day-to-day finances. And I think if I was in my 20s and I still lived at home, that'd be all right. I probably would make that work. But now
完全正确。我尽量把它当作给孩子们的人生一课，教他们如何做预算，思考把钱花在什么地方最合适。我认为这是我们在学校里并不总是能学到的一项生活技能——或者我当年没有学到。但是的，你显然必须一只眼睛盯着餐桌上的食物和收入，而且你知道的，就像我读硕士时需要买一台笔记本电脑一样，现在那台电脑差不多已经过时了。所以如果我真的考上了博士，我还需要买一台。总是有各种东西在与日常财务发生冲突。我想如果我才 20 多岁，还和父母住在一起，那倒没问题。我可能就能应付过去。但现在
you've got to spend a bit more time thinking about it. Absolutely. To my knowledge, no doctor no doctorate course gives their new trainees a laptop whereas in converse when my nephew started a media course at his university he was given a macbook or is even a mac i don't know some kind of expensive tech but you do not get that even though it's going to be an essential criteria of your job you don't get given that yet if you are being employed as a band seven you would be getting probably a laptop that you can use to take home and work from home or work remotely at different sites whereas to my knowledge that isn't routinely done in doctoral training courses. No I don't know much about that but I can assume not and but even bringing it back
你必须花更多时间去考虑这些。绝对的。据我所知，没有任何一个博士课程会给他们的第新培训生配备笔记本电脑，而相比之下，当我侄子在大学开始修读媒体课程时，他得到了一台 MacBook，甚至是一台 Mac，我不知道，某种昂贵的科技产品。但你却得不到，尽管这将会是你工作的一项基本标准，但你就是分不到。然而，如果你被雇佣为第 7 级员工，你可能会得到一台可以带回家、在家办公或在不同地点远程办公的笔记本电脑，但据我所知，博士培训课程中通常不会这样做。
to the AP roles I've just interviewed for one and part of the criteria was to have a car so for me and my family we need two cars for that very kind of predicament that just getting in around the northwest you know and but if I didn't have that second car like many families don't what would I have done again I'm priced out Anna of applying for that role absolutely and even the cost of insuring a car these days especially if you are in your early 20s that is outlandishly expensive and of course you know for the trainee psychology doctorate in clinical psychology it's a prerequisite that you have a driving license and access to a vehicle and that is a whole nother ethical conversation but it certainly continues this kind of entitled
不，我对那方面了解不多，但我可以假设确实没有。而且即使把它拉回到 AP 的职位上，我最近刚刚面试了一个岗位，其条件之一就是拥有一辆汽车。对我跟我的家人来说，我们需要两辆车来应付这种特定的困境——在西北部四处奔波。但是，如果我没有这第二辆车（就像许多家庭一样），我该怎么办呢？再次说明，我被这个职位的申请资格给“价格排挤”了，安娜。完全正确。甚至现在给汽车买保险的费用，尤其是如果你刚 20 出头的话，也是贵得离谱。当然，你知道的，对于临床心理学博士培训来说，拥有驾照和可以使用车辆是一个先决条件，这完全是另一个伦理对话，但它确实延续了这种关于“特权的负担能力”的讨论。
affordability discussion too yeah when i did the application for the first time last year it really got me to think about my social graces and you know my privileges and although I'm more aware I kind of think being in this industry it's feeding the privilege you know it's kind of I don't know if that's the right way of putting it but we almost have to stay privileged to stay in this line of work yeah and there's only so much reflection that we can do you know the maths is not mathing as they say in the states which is one of my all-time favorite sayings i have to say the maths is not mathing like you can't suddenly reflect differently on it and have more money in your purse like you know only so many ways you
是的，去年我第一次申请时，它真的让我开始思考我的社会阶层（social graces）以及我的特权。虽然我更有意识了，但我总觉得身处这个行业就是在喂养特权。这有点……我不知道这样说对不对，但我们几乎必须保持特权才能留在这个行业。是的，我们能做的反思是有限的，你知道的，正如美国人常说的那样，“数学没对上”（the maths is not mathing）。这是我最喜欢的名言之一，我必须得说，“数学没对上”。你不能突然对它进行不同的反思，然后你的钱包里就有了更多的钱。你知道的，你只能通过有限的方式
can tighten your belt to be able to stay within this profession. And I know that, you know, someone who's perhaps getting on to a doctoral training route that might have had two, maybe three assistant psychologist roles at band four, maybe tipping into band five. But in order to get the relevant experience roles, perhaps when they were 21, they did some access routes, which would have been probably less than band four. So, you know, you might be looking at five or six years of band three, band four, band five work before you can progress to a band six role and beyond. Yeah. And that's not even taken into consideration,
勒紧裤腰带，才能留在这个行业里。我知道，你知道的，有些人在进入博士培训途径时，可能已经做过两三份第 4 级的助理心理学家工作，也许还涉足过第 5 级。但为了获得相关的经验岗位，也许当他们 21 岁时，他们走了一些预科途径，这些途径的薪酬可能比第 4 级还要低。所以，你知道的，在你能够晋升到第 6 级及以上职位之前，你可能需要经历 5 到 6 年的第 3 级、第 4 级、第 5 级的工作。是的。这甚至还没有把以下情况考虑在内：
the kind of volunteering work that we might have to do or, you know, want to do. But I can't volunteer anymore. I just don't have the time or the spare cash to allow childcare to do that in order to have it on my CV, in order to gain enough experience to be able to apply for AP roles or the D-Climb. Gosh, isn't that an interesting moral debate that actually someone in a volunteer role is actually paying to be there because of the overheads they have to allow their presence? Oh, that is so big. And I love the idea of volunteering volunteering I'm really passionate about it I believe that we should we should all try to do something you know no matter what it is that we're into to give back but like I say right now just not I'm not able to do that but even in terms of like my counselling career there's an expectation that you'll do hours for free to build
我们可能不得不做、或者想要做的志愿工作。但我再也不能做志愿者了。我根本没有时间，也没有多余的现金来支付托儿费用，以换取简历上的这段经历，从而获得申请 AP 岗位或临床心理学博士学位的足够经验。天哪，这难道不是一个有趣的道德辩论吗？实际上，处于志愿者岗位的人因为必须承担维持出勤的开销，等于是在花钱去上班。哦，这个话题太大了。我喜欢做志愿者的想法，我对此充满热情，我相信我们都应该尽力去做点什么——无论我们喜欢什么——去回馈社会。但正如我所说，眼下我就是做不到。甚至在我的咨询师职业生涯方面，也有这样一种期望：你得免费工作多少小时，才能积累达到资格要求的小时数。我认为这在咨询行业并非个例，我想 CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗师也必须完成一定数量的小时数。这再次助长了这样一种观念：我觉得我们被低估了，而且我们倾注了如此多的关爱，做着这些岗位的人，你知道的，我们被利用了。因为我们想做好工作，所以没有人真正站出来说：“其实你们需要更多的钱，或者你们需要更多的薪水和认可。”
up the amount that you have to do to qualify I think I don't think that's standalone for counselling either I think you have to do a certain amount of hours for CBT therapists again it just feeds into this idea of like I think we're undervalued and I think the way that we care so much and and the people that are doing these roles you know we're kind of taken advantage of you know we want to do it so no one really stands up to say actually you need more money or you need more pay or recognition. Absolutely they know that they've got us over a barrel so to speak because we do care and we are moved by the distress of others and so we are more likely to be able to well to keep tolerating bad treatment and i don't think this podcast episode is going to be you know it's not
完全正确。他们知道我们被他们“拿捏”了，可以这么说，因为我们在乎，我们被他人的痛苦所打动，所以我们更有可能——嗯——继续容忍糟糕的对待。我不认为这期播客能改变什么，这也是一个令人悲伤的承认，但它至少能让人希望提高对道德困境的认识，不仅是荣誉岗位的道德困境（这当然是另一期播客的话题），而且实际上作为进入心理学的入门途径，带薪工作也存在道德困境和两难选择。是的，我觉得它无处不在，不是吗？并且是这个行业的一部分。最终，你只能决定你愿意接受什么，你能为自己和家人决定什么样的变通办法，什么对你最好，然后坚持下去。你知道，尽管有时我一个月的财务状况很好，有时会更艰难一些，但每个人不都是这样的吗？
going to change anything and that's that's kind of a sad admission but it will at least have people hopefully become more aware of the ethical dilemmas not just of the honorary roles which of course was a separate podcast episode but there's actually also ethical dilemmas and quandaries in paid work as entry routes into psychology yeah i think it's it's everywhere isn't it and not parts of the industry i think ultimately you just have to decide what you're willing to accept and what workarounds you can decide upon for you and your family and what's best for you and run with that you know despite you know sometimes i'll have a great month financially sometimes it'll be a little bit more tough but that's the same for everyone
我们只能量入为出。确实如此。好吧，我希望你作为一名合格咨询师的工作一切顺利，我也很高兴看到你能走到哪一步。等你听到助理心理学家面试结果后，我很想知道结果。非常感谢你敞开心扉开启这次对话，不仅鼓励了我，也鼓励了我们在 YouTube 上的观众以及在各个平台上收听播客的听众，探讨这个非常重要的考量。不客气，我认为谈论钱很重要。我们谈论得还不够。这是一个“禁忌话题”，对吧？但它是通往临床心理学博士学位之旅的一部分。好的，在结束之前，萨姆，还有什么
isn't it and and we just have to cut our cloth accordingly yes indeed well i hope that your role as a qualified counsellor is going really well for you and i'm excited to see where you get i'd love to know the outcome of your assistant psychologist interview once you hear back from them thank you so much for you know opening up this conversation and encouraging not just myself but our our watchers on youtube and our listeners um wherever people get their podcasts on this really important consideration are you welcome i think it's important to talk about money we don't talk about it enough it's one of those to be's isn't it but it's um it's part of the the journey into the declimb okay just before we finish sam is there anything
是我们没有聊到、但你觉得对我们的观众很有参考价值的吗？我认为重要的是要考虑到，我们的旅程从我们开始上大学时就已经开始了。我是家里第一代上大学的人，我妈妈不管对错，只是对我说：“做你喜欢的事，学艺术吧。”于是我就学了艺术。但后来，随着我作为一个人不断成长，意识到我想做什么、我想如何在心理健康领域工作时，在财务上我无法再读一个本科了。直到多年后我才意识到，我可以拿到另一笔资金去读硕士和转换专业。但所有这一切都在财务上对我的临床心理学博士之路产生了影响。我只是觉得我们常常忘记，我们的一些财务故事早在我们目前的处境之前的多年前就已经开始了。确实如此。实际上，就
that we've not spoken about that you think might be useful for our our viewers to to consider i think it's important to consider that our journey starts from when we start university and I was first generation in my family to go to university and my mum rightly or wrongly just said do something that you enjoy do art and so I did but then when I started to grow as a person and realize what I wanted to do and how I wanted to work in mental health financially I couldn't do another undergrad and then it wasn't until years later that I realized I could get another pot of money to do a master's and do a conversion but all of this has impacted on my journey to the decline financially I just think we kind of forget that some of our financial story starts years before where we are now. It really does. And actually, in terms of
我们所认为的“金钱创伤”而言，你知道的，也许我们也承载着来自未来几代人的东西，关于我们能做什么或应该做什么，我们能赚多少钱或应该赚多少钱，以及像我们这样的人是否应该上大学。这真的非常非常重要。非常感谢你的时间，萨姆。谢谢。非常感谢今天的嘉宾萨姆。我希望你觉得这是一次有趣且有见地的对话。你怎么看？请在评论区告诉我。请点赞、订阅、分享给你的朋友。如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请给节目评分和评论。在 Spotify 上，你可以进行评分。我非常期待你的反馈。快来
what we think about as money trauma, you know, perhaps we're carrying stuff from future generations as well for kind of what we could or should be doing, what we could or should be earning and, you know, whether people like us should be at university even. Really, really important. Thank you so much for your time, Sam. Thank you. Thank you so much to my guest today, Sam. I hope you found this to be an interesting and insightful conversation. What do you think? Let me know in the comments. Please do like, subscribe, share with your friends. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review the show. Spotify, you can rate. And I would love your feedback. Come and connect
在社交媒体上与我联系吧，我到处都是“Dr. Marianne Trent”。告诉我你的想法。我关心你所关心的。所以告诉我你的想法。如果你希望获得更多支持和指导来思考你的反思和职业发展，请务必查看《有志心理学家集体书》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）和《临床心理学家集体书》（Clinical Psychologist Collective book）。如果你想加入“有志心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist community）——这是我的免费 Facebook 群组，也是玛丽安的
with me on socials where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Let me know. I care about what you care about. So let me know what you think. If you would welcome some more support and guidance in thinking about your reflection and your career development, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. If you would like to come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community, which is my free Facebook group and is the exclusive home of Marianne's
动力与心态专场的独家聚集地，请务必加入。你会受到热烈欢迎。如果时机已成熟，你已准备好迈出下一步，这里还有“有志心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），你只需每月 30 英镑即可加入，没有最低期限限制。当你加入时，你将可以访问自会员计划推出以来的所有回放录音，
motivation and mindset sessions, please do so. You'd be so welcome. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, there's the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. And when you do that, you get access to all of the replay recordings since the launch
所以它的性价比极其惊人。让它成为你的指南。有这个播客伴你左右，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的“有志心理学家播客”。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名心理健康实习干事。我读了《临床心理学家集体书》，我发现里面关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少不同的途径可以到达那里，这让我大为惊叹，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心：不，我没有做错，并且减轻了我自己的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你心安理得，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
of the membership. So it is incredible value. be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
会员资格的一部分。所以它的价值惊人。成为你的向导。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向合格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我的名字叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，觉得里面关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少不同的途径可以到达那里，这让我感到惊叹，成为临床心理学家没有完美的方式，这让我充满了信心，认为我并没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。因此，如果您对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，以让您安心，一切都会好的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。